DNS domains are structured as a tree.
Domains such as google.com and
udacity.com do share something,
the com top-level domain.
There's actually a collection of
servers who are responsible for
storing all of the records for
domains in com, and
in org and edu and
each other top-level domain,
including country code demands
like uk and il and ua [INAUDIBLE].
Now, www.example.com Is
a subdomain of example.com.
And test.www.example.com
is a subdomain of that.
Now, there's no rule that you can't have
hosts at any level of these subdomains.
You can have a host with an IP address
and an A record on one domain and
then have a subdomain of that
with a different host on it.
Now, early in the history of the web
it was common for an institution whose
domain was, let's say, stanford.edu to
have its web server at www.stanford.edu.
And that would have typically been
a single machine that was the web server
representing the institution.
But these days, since so many
domains are used almost entirely for
web traffic,
many organizations skip the www and
just point their domain
directly to a web server.
Like github.com for instance.
The name www.github.com is a C-Name,
an alias, for the A record, github .com.
Whether to use bare domains
like GitHub does or
www domains like Udacity does is pretty
much a style and branding preference.
There's little technical difference.
For computers within an organization,
it's pretty common for
them to also have
a configured search domain.
This tells the resolver on that
computer to look up hosts inside that
domain first.
Like if you're on the network
of the university, example.edu,
you might have that in
your search domain.
Then when you look up the DNS name www,
the resolver will look for
www.example.edu first.